we've got an update on that gun control
rally that's c9 held last week after the
event a high school student called
Colton hob claimed that CNN tried to
give him a scripted question to ask on
camera Colton came on this show last
week on Thursday to tell his story
CNN denied the account now Colton and
his parents sent us their email
correspondence with CNN which seemed to
confirm Colton's claim that his question
had been altered by a CNN producer on
Friday we asked CNN to verify uncomment
on those emails because that was our
journalistic duty so we did it a short
time before air CNN provided us a
different set of emails we immediately
asked the hobs about those they said
they were being slandered by CNN and
that's where it stood two sides telling
contradictory stories without access to
their email accounts we could only guess
which one was telling the truth and
guessing is not enough tonight we have
more we have an update the hub family
concedes that they did remove a line
from one of their emails in a way that
might make some think its meaning had
changed Colton's father says it was
accidental we don't know we can't prove
or disprove that but for the sake of
honesty and full disclosure to which we
are committed we have to tell you there
is no evidence as of right now that CNN
tried to give Colton hob a scripted
question and we wanted you to know that